New research thinks it
knows how many people you
are going to kiss
before you settle down.
Challenge accepted.
Anthony here for D
News and you know,
with it being the new
year, Valentine's Day
looming in the distance, we
tend to think a lot about love,
comparing our lives to others,
figuring out how we're doing.
Where do we stack up to
the rest of the world
in the hunt for true love?
Well, author Graeme
Simsion released
a novel last year called
The Rosie Project.
It's all about a guy who
uses surveys and big data
to try and find
the optimal wife.
Cute idea and a really
appropriate one because Simsion
worked in data
modeling and research
before becoming a writer.
Dude even had a
Ted Talk about it.
So it's no surprise that
as part of his research,
he did some, well, research.
He surveyed 2,000
people in the UK
to see just what the average
romantic life for men and women
is before they find the one.
And according to his data,
women will kiss 15 people
before they settle down.
Men will kiss 15.
On average, women will be
stood up for a date once.
It'll happen to men twice.
That's cold, ladies.
Women will have seven sexual
partners and four one night
stands while men have
10 partners and six one
night stands.
Both will live with someone
once before finding the person
that they will
live with forever.
And in both cases,
someone's probably
going to lose a nice couch.
Before you start tallying
your scores compared
to other people, you
should know people
lie like crazy on these surveys.
Seriously, Norman
Brown, a psychologist
from the University of Michigan,
noticed that in most surveys,
men were reporting two to
four times as many lifetime
sexual partners as women.
In a particular study that
he ran of 2,000 people,
women reported eight average
partners and men claimed 32.
Those numbers do not add up,
you guys, so he got sneaky.
A question at the end of
the survey asked, hey,
did you lie back there, like at
the sexual partners question?
And 5% of the respondents
immediately said yes.
10% said they
didn't lie, but they
knew that their answer
probably wasn't accurate.
Called out, y'all.
But it's not just lying.
There is an interesting
thing about how
men and women calculate their
answers to these questions.
Women use a raw count.
They actually go through a list
in their heads in the moment.
That's a method that actually
leads to under-reporting
because you might forget
someone or, you know,
want to forget someone.
Men are more likely to
use rough approximation,
just straight up guess
based on what feels right,
and that's a method that tends
to lead to over-reporting
because instead of leaving
out people you forget,
you add in how many people
you think you're forgetting.
You know, like I
slept with probably
like a bunch of models.
You don't know them.
They live in Niagara Falls
or whatever, I guess.
I mean, not that
I've ever done that.
You can't entirely
trust data like this,
and even if you could, why
compare yourself to others?
Natural curiosity is
fine, but it's important
not to actually use
this stuff as some sort
of a yardstick
for your own life.
Average does not mean normal.
It doesn't matter if your
numbers skew higher or lower
on this stuff because
everyone's life is different.
Average just crushes
all of human experience
into one number,
although if your goal is
to smooch more people in the
new year, I say have at it
because smooching is great.
You know, I honestly compare
my life to other people's way
more than I should, but I'm
getting better about it.
How about you?
Tell me the comments and
subscribe for more D News.